اقتران تويتر باسمي له ماسك ما زالت
اصداؤه تتوالى كل ما هدات امواج صفقه
الاستحواذ على الشركه الاقتصاديه تتعالى
من جديد من الجانب السياسيه هذه المره قد
يقف ماسك في مواجهه محتمله مع بيض الذي
صرح بانه يجب التحقيق بعلاقات ماسك بالدول
اجنبيه وتاثيرها على الامن القومي
شكل كوره
تويتر
على مستوى مجلس النواب
باب الخلاف بين بيض وماسك بعد تهنئه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب له على صفقه
استحواذ تويتر انا سعيد جدا لان تويتر
اصبحت الان في ايد امينه ولن يديرها بعد
الان مجانين يساريون راديكاليون يكرهون
بلدنا بالفعل
تطور دفع بيض لمهاجمه مصر بقوه ما يقلقنا
الان جميعا هو قيامه ايلون ماسك بشراء
اداه ترسل وتنشر الاكاذيب في انحاء العالم
كيف نتوقع ان يتحلى الاطفال بالقدره على
ادراك المخاطر
فانتقد مؤخرا وضع الاقتصاد الامريكي في ظل
ادارته
الاقتصاد الامريكي في حاله ركود وارتفاع
الاسعار نتيجه بسيطه لطباعه النقود ادعو
الشركات لمراقبه تكاليف والتدفقات النقديه
سواء داخل الولايات المتحده او خارجها لا
يتوقف ماسك عن اثاره الجدل بارائه
السياسيه فمن تقديم مقترح لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه وصولا الى حل ازمه تايوان
والصين تتعرض اراء ماسك مع توجهات
الادارات الامريكيه الحاليه وهو ما قد
يصاعد من حده الخلاف وعواقبه على تويتر
علي السمان العربيه